autour de la table on revient d'un peu
partout en france et ont pas de porte
eric henninot clermont ferrand ils ne se
connaissent pas mais ils ont tous payé
250 euros pour apprendre à cuisiner le
foie gras le temps d'un week end
voilà c'est le pet aussi découvrir
l'autre le foie les autres michel et
henry ont la soixantaine passée à la
retraite ils ont ouvert cette maison
d'hôtes dans un coin complètement perdu
dans les landes pour faire venir du
monde il organise depuis cinq ans des
séjours où il est interdit de mettre les
pieds sous la table
tout le monde doit prêter la main on
devrait apprendre c'est chez royal
chanter avec la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat les rtt c'est la grande tendance
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
vous évader le temps d'un week end trois
jours maxi l'année dernière les français
ont dépensé quelque 6 milliards 400
millions d'euros pour partir en week end
quelques jours alors tâche pour
apprendre à faire du foie gras à
découvrir le vin ou journée dans une
bergerie pour faire du fromage soi même
il y en a pour toutes les bouches
et pour toutes les bourses 250 à 600
euros le prix à payer pour découvrir
notre patrimoine culinaire retour dans
les landes
nous retrouvons nos vacanciers qui ont
passé la nuit dans les chambres d'hôtes
de michal et henry ils sont venus dans
le sud-ouest pour apprendre à faire le
canard à la royale et ils vont être
servis en ruine et conduite chez un
éleveur des environs
des milliers de petits canards adorable
qui vont tous finir comme ça mais avant
de le manger
ils vont devoir le découper alors déjà
vous couper les pattes
je pense que ça c'est pas très compliqué
place aux travaux pratiques
pour un peu on se croirait presque dans
une salle d'opération
pour raymonde en revanche ça
ressemblerait plutôt à une salle de
torture
et sur ce n'est pas mon métier raymonde
n'en fera peut-être pas son métier mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'en découpant
fois même son canard on peut réaliser de
belles économies dans le commerce le
magret ses 20 euros le kilo le foie gras
150 euros alors qu'en achetant le canard
entier
ça revient cinq fois moins cher un
canard entier 6 euros le kilo ça vous
fait un canard à peu près entre 35 et 40
euros donc imaginez avait tout ce que
vous avez sur la table la ville yonne
que vous avez pour 6 euros le kilo
typique de septembre à avril une bonne
centaine de touristes viennent chez
thierry pour apprendre à désosser une
bête que l'on farci de foie gras le
fameux canard à la royale et pour tirer
comme on dit ici ça met du gras de
canard c'est comme un chiffre d'affaires
on va dire de 10 12 15 mille euros par
an ce qui n'est pas négligeable pour
dont on a besoin et il a pensé à tout
thierry pas question de laisser partir
ses autres sens d'abord les faire passer
par la case de sa petite boutique privé
canard aux vins garbure koffi
récit démentir est aussi à l'aise dans
sa blouse que dans les habits du vendeur
en moyenne les touristes repartent avec
100 euros de marchandise et bien sûr
leurs cannes à royal sous le bras
désormais plus de la moitié des français
délaissent l'habituel petite semaine de
vacances au profit de court séjour à
moins de 200 kilomètres de chez eux
bertrand a été le premier à se
positionner sur le créneau des week-ends
thématiques
il est à peine midi et les réservations
tourne déjà à plein régime
750 rêvant depuis ce matin un petit
week-end en roulotte fait une cure de
fromage en auvergne ou encore fabriquer
du miel en provence avec bertrand tout
est possible le secret de son succès il
a su anticiper les désirs des
consommateurs
alors on les fait bon joueur on leur
fait faire et découvrir des choses et je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'ils
s'enrichissent plus dans un week-end est
ce plus facile à faire parce qu'on
protège pour se dépatouiller je vais
dans cette totale pour que je trouve le
fermier que je trouve la fromagère d'un
nom est toujours ensemble le fromage la
fromagère l hôtel en un seul passage on
facilite la vie des gens il y a deux ans
ils n'étaient que cinq aujourd'hui ils
sont 50 dans le bureau et son chiffre
d'affaires a de quoi faire rêver
n'importe quel start up
cette année on finira propres à 30
millions de chiffre
on va faire 150 une réservation cloud
poids de 100 euros voilà ça devrait
faire un pas vers un sas rapt à puce ça
sera probablement pas moins et devant
cet engouement pour les courts séjours
les idées ne manquent pas laurent et
sommeliers et aujourd'hui s'il est en
bourgogne ce n'est pas pour visiter les
célèbres cave
mais tout bonnement pour tester la
literie des demeures de charme
laurent vient de lancer des séjours haut
de gamme autour du vin c'est 15 week end
ont trouvé preneur aussi sec
du coup il lui faut trouver d'autres
chambres d'hôtes de luxe pour accueillir
ces nouveaux clients donc on peut
envisager aussi de prendre le petit
déjeuner au pied des vignes
d'accord c'est exactement ce qu'ils
cherchent maintenant il va falloir
négocier
il nous faudrait un tarif qu'ils soient
situés avec les petits déjeuners aux
alentours de 100 120 120 euros la
chambre pour lui mais à sept ans cent
vingt ans là c'est plutôt dans les 200
euros
alors ce sera pour une autre fois si
laurent mégote sur les prix c'est que
hôtels restaurants transports tout doit
tenir dans les 500 euros par personne
ici des clients qui prennent leur
voiture et qui font la route des vins on
en croise tout le temps qu alors laurent
en profite pour séduire de nouveaux
clients
le problème c'est qu'il faut prendre la
voiture donc ce président il faut aussi
le voir le moins possible oui mais la
formule de laurent un avantage
indéniable à des week-ends oenologique
avec chauffeur et a souligné keith
hackett à votre disposition vous n'avez
pas à vous soucier de la route vous
n'avez pas à vous soucier par où passent
et on vous fait passer dans les vignes
trois jours dans le vignoble avec de
nuit et tout est inclus vous avez la
restauration un chauffeur qui ne boit
pas il fallait y penser
et voici la surprise que laurent réserve
à ses futurs clients
la visite privée du château de meursault
jean-claude le régisseur du domaine
possède un million de bouteilles
il y en a pour 40 millions d'euros les
touristes de laurent ont un fort pouvoir
d'achat alors pour le décider à faire un
petit tour chez lui jean claude va lui
sortir une bouteille de prestige ça
reste toujours un grand moment quand on
ouvre un vieux flacons comme ça c'est
toujours des moments d'exception
oui mais voilà le cru 1990 et 300 euros
la bouteille alors pour la faire
déguster à ses clients il ne faut pas
compter dessus on peut pas ouvrir une
bouteille aussi vieille que sage aussi
rare que ça de façon de façon spontanée
on est d'accord
par contre le l'acquisition à l'unité de
cette bouteille la halle sera possible
par fait le bon sens bourguignon ça en
quatre mois laurent devrait engranger
plus de 20000 euros grâce à ses
week-ends de luxe le sommelier ne s'y
connaît pas quand vint il a aussi la
bosse des affaires
mais si on veut s'offrir du dépaysement
pour beaucoup moins cher ça existe aussi
nous sommes à nice valérie tatiana avait
envie de renouer avec la nature et de
réaliser un rêve de gosse quand j'étais
petit je voulais être
je voulais travailler dans une ferme
elles vont passer toute une journée à
travailler chez geneviève et daniel et
le comble c'est que pour s'occuper des
chevaux faire gambader les oies nourrir
les cochons c'est elle qui vont payer 50
euros par personne mais il ya une
contrepartie
ici à côté de nice ont fait un fromage
de chève hors pair les plus grands
palaces de la côte d'azur ci fournissent
et c'est rodolphe le fils qui se charge
de la livraison des produits
je ferai en baron voilà même le prince
albert et brad pitt en raffolent en
échange de leurs efforts
valérie tatiana vont avoir le privilège
de connaître leurs secrets de
fabrication
mais avant cela il faut d'abord du lait
est rare des chefs c'est franchement
plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît pour
faire un fromage de cette qualité ça
prend au minimum quatre heures par jour
entre retourner le fromage de la veille
mettre le lait du matin à kayes et
remplir les pots à la louche et faire
sécher les chèvres dans la fille noire
on peut dire que c'est du boulot un
travail compliqué mais c'est
ce fait que télé
vous êtes en vie
tatiana elle est temps d'aller par cette
journée à la ferme
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que je
vais rentrer à la maison je vais essayer
parce que ça m'a donné beaucoup invite
essayer si genève organise ce genre de
stage ce n'est pas vraiment pour
l'argent ça lui rapporte à peine 1000
euros par an dans le but de montrer
notre ferme de montrer qu'on peut vivre
par amour et pas forcément que par achat
voilà c'est un peu le message que je
veux dire combien ça coûte ça peut être
aussi de l'amour tac la france regorge
de spécialités de terroirs différents
pour apprendre à tout faire à tout
connaître et à tous goûté il va falloir
en passer des week-ends gourmands